bonjour à vous mais ca d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france nouvelles
restrictions donc annoncé hier à par le
gouvernement qui concerne les
restaurants comment est ce que vous
voyez cette fin d'année
la fin d'année va on va la passer en
essayant de quand même d'être
optimiste mais c'est surtout le début
d'année qui va être très difficile pour
notre corporation cas déjà énormément
souffert et on va recommencer encore et
encore à faire de l'information de la
prévention et après battu contrôle et ça
va être très très difficile et surtout
la baisse d'activité qui va arriver sûr
et certain pour le début d'année
juste concernant cette fin d'année
évidemment les festivités du nouvel an
ça représente combien en chiffre
d'affaires
le chiffre d'affaires sur sur les faire
dernier pour nous reste quand même sur
le plus gros chiffre d'affaires
puisqu'on puisse avoir c'est nous ça
représente sur un chiffre d'affaires de
2,2 ce mois on va dire que ça va 30 à 40
% de notre chiffre d'affaires qui va qui
va partir sur 70 de femmes elle et
j'ai eu déjà les restrictions qui avait
eu donc il ya déjà eu du monde le
personnel on n'a pas pu on n'a pas
embauché on a laissé partir du personnel
et c'est surtout qu'on n'a pas pu
prévoir cette fin d'année du coup qu'il
y en avait une restitution noël sont
tombés nous ça a été quasiment 90 %
d'annulations sur la période du 24 et du
du coup ça nous a mis un récit sans fin
pour moi est réticente sur les achats en
plus qui avaient énormément exposé sur
sur le mois et ça fait que du coup alors
on se dit est ce qu'on va ouvrir est-ce
qu'on va pas ouvrir est ce qu'il y aura
assez de monde pour que supporter ça
donc ses proches grosse grosse grosse
perte sur le chiffre le chiffre de ces
alors vous êtes un gérant je le rappelle
d'un bar restaurant à redon en ille et
vilaine vous avez apparemment décidé de
fermer votre restaurant car vous
expliquez vous pouvez plus tenir avec
vos équipes racontez nous
dans nos équipes on a décidé de fermer
enfin j'ai décidé
qu'on fait qu'on allait fermer la juste
après le 31 mai parce que l'équipe pas
d'équipé tombeur de burnout on va dire
nous tous en train de leur demander de
s'investir de s'investir et donc hélas
ils ont tous tous tous besoin de de voir
autre chose
de couper et de réfléchir sur tours
alors à venir
donc et en plus normalement on roule ça
j'en ai juste avec l'instauration de
checa texte fort sur le pass vaccinale
on va parler évidemment de on va parler
de ce pass vaccinale mais d'abord
concernant vos droits et ce qui va se
passer pour les personnes qui
travaillent avec vous est ce que vous
avez le droit au chômage partiel
ça va être si la grosse question on est
avec les comptables justement pour pour
pour voir ça
est-ce qu'on va avoir droit au chômage
partiel c'est qu'on va continuer à
pouvoir pêcher cette compensation qui va
énormément nous manquer et combien de
temps combien de temps bon c'est vrai
que c'est triste à dire
confinement
ça va peut-être été mieux mais bon
j'aime pas pour nous là il faut
absolument que trouver de l'aide pour
tous pour tous les cafetiers et les
restaurateurs parce que ce pass
vaccinale va mettre tout le monde très
très très mal
demander en quinze jours impasse
vaccinale
nous on est une clientèle d'affaires je
vois difficilement mes clients ils
n'auront pas le 22 passes vaccinale
total donc c'est les trois
injections et ou ayant une clientèle
d'affaires comme un commercial qui vit
en restaurant tout temps on va pas lui
demander son pass sanitaires et un test
pcr c'est pas possible ou qu'est ce
qu'on va faire
comment comment est ce qu'on va pouvoir
nous aider comme
comment il va falloir justifier
justement ce cette perte de chiffre
d'affaires due à des
inspirations qui pour nous sont beaucoup
trop court et parfois souvent ne nous
lâche pas
voilà on est contrôlé les amendes les
amendes augmente on voit très très très
difficile
on va avoir besoin d'être c'est sûr
alors vous allez avoir besoin d'être ça
va être très compliqué de travailler
dans ces conditions
ce pass vaccinale c'est un peu la goutte
d'eau qui fait déborder le vase
à votre niveau
oui nos sociétés où il cherchait on a
rouvert après confinement on a été plein
de petits michelin on s'est mis en eau a
dit bon vaccin obligatoire des jaloux
pour tous les moments du personnel à
partir du 30 août ça a été très rapide
et il a fallu se vacciner déjà avoir des
rendez-vous on n'était pas friand été
rasés dans le plasma donc on est quand
même fait partie de la masse salariale
inquiets des dégâts thouars très très
vite pour tous les collaborateurs
ensuite pour les clients ou non france
se dit oui on va faire on va faire on va
faire on va faire et puis là le pass
vaccinale qui tombe non bah non non on
sera content après par de kerjean et
c'est sûr et sain
pour que qu'est ce qu'on va faire est-ce
qu'on va être contrôlé ce qui va encore
y avoir des tolérances comment on va
faire avec l'équipe de collaborateurs
pour qu'ils soient tous leurs trois
injections
alors donc
là où il ya un gros creux ras-le-bol qui
fait que c'est surtout ça qui va
décourager certains de mes
collaborateurs
et tué après par rapport par rapport à
nos clients gagnent on va on va perdre
juste pour se terminer à vous demander
des compensations clairement au
gouvernement une aide concrète
aujourd'hui
oui oui oui
oui je le cache envier j'ai peur j'ai
peur d'avoir un contrôle j'ai peur je
peux pas tout ce qui va ce qu'il va se
passer je
dois essayer de reprendre du courage et
d'être de reprendre de l'opgi mais voilà
que qu'est ce qu'on va faire qu'est-ce
que pour moi on va boucler nos fins de
mois
c'est surtout ça merci à vous pour ce
témoignage de le reste rbs rappelle que
vous êtes un gérant d'un bar restaurant
en ille et vilaine et bon courage à vous
merci merci